hey you guys welcome back to my flickers
of fear show we have a very interesting
one to talk about today uh this is one
that came out back in 2009
and it's called jennifer's body
now interestingly i kind of had heard
about this one like around the fringes
of horrordam i guess
but i didn't realize until i
watched it and started doing a deep dive
into behind the scenes kind of stuff
what happened when it first came out i
didn't realize what a big kerfuffle
there was
about this movie when it came out and
how in recent years starting around 2018
2019 i want to say um it's kind of got a
big critical reassessment and a lot of
people have kind of reclaimed it and
it's sort of become a cult classic now
as i said it just seems like
i kind of like missed the train on it
like when it first came out i kind of
like was interested to see it because it
had been written by diablo cody who also
had written juno and had won a uh an
academy award for that uh the screenplay
like a year or two before this came out
so i thought it was like interesting
that she was doing a horror movie now
because she said she'd always wanted to
do one and but for whatever reason i
just never got around to seeing it
now this movie interestingly i feel like
this movie
was way way
like ahead of his time i i think if it
came out now
i think it would be a much bigger
success i think what ended up happening
with this one
was uh several things so we'll get into
that and i kind of want to talk about
that like before i get into talking
about the actual movie
so when this came out in 2009 as i said
the screenwriter was diablo cody she had
won an academy award for juno and i kind
of feel like because she was sort of
this new voice and she was being lauded
everywhere there was inevitably kind of
like a backlash
now i can't say too much about juno i
did see it in the theater and i remember
liking it but i haven't seen it since
then so i don't know how well it holds
up
i know that some people are not a fan of
diablo cody's
um screenwriting in the sense that she
kind of writes things that have these
very like
i guess affected or maybe overly
precious
uh slang that she makes up so how you
feel about that is kind of like how
you're gonna feel about her
work in general i don't remember it
bothering me when i saw juno uh in the
theater so it doesn't bother me and
jennifer's body either uh and it's not i
feel like in jennifer's body it's not as
egregious but as i said i haven't seen
it in
you know i haven't seen juno for a very
long time but honestly it kind of
strikes me the same way that you know
the sort of made up slang in heathers
struck me
um so it doesn't really bother me all
that much it's like oh teenagers don't
really talk like that i'm like yeah they
didn't really talk like that in
heather's either but they were just
trying to establish the the movie
universe's own patois if you want to say
that so it didn't really bother me all
that much
so there was a big backlash against
diablo cody i guess like people saying
it's like oh she wasn't really that
great a screenwriter it's just she just
leans on all these kind of like edgy
you know crazy overly precious like i
said sort of uh you know witticisms and
things like that so there was that
then there was megan fox uh who stars in
this movie as the titular jennifer
and she was
sort of like the hot it girl at the time
she'd been on maxim she was in the
transformers movies but again uh around
the time that jennifer's body came out
there was also a big backlash against
her
mostly because of some [ __ ] that she
said about michael bay who was the
director of transformers now i've read
the quotes of what she said and it was
um a little over the top but
not really that bad in context yes she
did say he was kind of like hitler in
the sense that uh he was like tyrannical
on the set but she did actually sort of
soften that a little bit later saying
it's like oh well when he's not on the
set like when i talk to him off the set
he's actually a very nice person so it's
not like she
you know like i said hitler that's a
little bit
that's a that's a little bit of
hyperbole sure
but what she said was
probably dumb and ill-considered but not
that bad in context i didn't think
but uh predictably
everybody got a kind of up in arms about
it uh in 2009 and just being like why
don't you just you know stay hot and
shut up it's like why even talking about
that and there it was even leaked a
letter that was allegedly
written by three crew members on some of
the transformers movies and it basically
i mean it said some pretty shitty things
about her like i said it's not some of
the [ __ ] she said about michael bay was
a little bit ill-advised um you know and
maybe kind of dumb like that she said
over you know just off the cuff and
everything
but
i mean the [ __ ] they said about her was
was kind of shitty you know what i mean
and i don't know how much michael bay
had to do with
that letter but he did host it on his
website for a time
and it did actually end up getting megan
fox fired from the transformers movie so
again there was kind of like a backlash
against her there so backlash against
the screenwriter backlash against the
main actress
and i think probably the main problem
with
when jennifer's body came out why it
didn't do all that well
was the marketing
because megan fox was starring in the
movie uh basically the marketing
department
was kind of like well we're just going
to
market this to teenage boys
and
our whole marketing uh slant is that
megan fox is hot that's pretty much it
uh so that was how they did all the
trailers were kind of like that uh you
know all the posters you know had you
know her kind of scantily clad on there
and to be honest uh the marketing didn't
really have [ __ ] to do with what the
movie was about
so i think that you know yeah maybe they
did succeed in reeling in teenage boys
even though this was r-rated so i
imagine they would have had to sneak in
or whatever or go with someone older
so even if they did sucker teen boys
into
going to see the movie
they didn't really get the movie they
were expecting and honestly uh diablo
cody and the director of this uh karen
kusama
who i mean they specifically said we
wanted to market this movie toward
girls toward teenage girls
because that's kind of what the heart of
the story was and we begged the
marketing department please do not
market it toward teenage well not the
teenage boys you know of a certain you
know certain teenage boys couldn't have
enjoyed it but i do think that they
really made a mistake marketing it as
this sort of like sexy
you know kind of funny
horror movie with
megan fox in it you know being sexy and
that's not really what it is uh and i
think it would have succeeded a lot more
had they listened to the director and
the screenwriter who specifically wanted
to gear this more toward girls young
women
and honestly i think they should have
done the same thing because and i'm not
the first person to point this out but
this movie is very much
similar to gingersnaps uh which had come
out
eight or nine years prior to this i
believe um in gingersnaps the two
protagonists are sisters and in this
they're best friends
but this does kind of explore a lot of
the same themes of
female
relationships teenage girls uh the
intensity of their relationships what
happens when
uh you know your best friend your sister
is essentially becomes a monster
uh you know so it does kind of explore a
lot of those themes so i think that it
would have been a lot more successful
had it been marketed toward a more
female-centric audience at the time as i
said that doesn't mean that you know
teenage boys or men or whatever couldn't
have enjoyed it i just think that they
should have marketed it more as what it
was rather than trying to make it into
something that it wasn't so i think
that's kind of why it failed
so interestingly it was this big uh you
know the movie got [ __ ] on it had you
know terrible reviews i think the only
the only positive sort of positive
review of it that i saw from kind of
like major critics at the time was from
roger ebert of all people um who you
know didn't love it but he thought it
was actually like way better than it had
any right to be uh but even he seemed to
kind of like misunderstand it like in
the
in the review
he actually called it like twilight for
boys and i was like that is absolutely
not what this baby is at all i don't
know where he's getting that from um i i
don't know i don't know where he's
getting that from but that's but he did
like it even though he the point of it
seemed to go entirely over his head but
like i said this is a movie that was
more
about teenage girls or geared toward
teenage girls and young women and you
know like an old dude is you know an old
dude is not going to really maybe get
that so i do kind of feel like i i don't
really like to say that like oh this
movie is like not for these people or
whatever but i do kind of feel like
obviously
certain kind of movies are gonna appeal
more to
certain types of demographics and i
think this is a much more
you know female-centric movie as like i
said in the same way that gingersnaps is
this almost kind of like reminds me of
ginger snaps mean girls heathers
that type of vibe so if you haven't seen
this and you like those types of movies
then you will probably really dig this
now it is a horror comedy
but there are some scenes in there that
are kind of like disturbing but it's
nice to see that because this movie got
so monumentally [ __ ] on and not just the
movie itself but megan fox uh who quit
acting for a time just because of the
blowback she got from this uh karen
kusama who went indie after this because
she was like [ __ ] that noise i'm not
like dealing with studios and marketing
departments like that anymore and uh you
know diablo cody who also kind of went
more indie and you can't really [ __ ]
blame them because some of the [ __ ] that
that these uh that these women got after
this movie came out for just for a
[ __ ] movie for crazy that like i said
it wasn't even their fault that it was
the marketing department that like
[ __ ] them on that one so but some of
the [ __ ] they had to put up with is just
horrifying so you can understand like
why they were just like yeah i don't
even want to deal with that but it is
nice to see that for whatever reason
somewhere around 2018 2019 um i think it
was kind of because megan fox was maybe
trying to like making a little bit of a
comeback or was in something kind of uh
high profile um a lot of people and
maybe it was because it was like around
the 10th anniversary of the movie as
well a lot of people started sort of
like reassessing this movie and i think
too that the movie that came out a
couple was it last year or the year
before promising young women i think
that coming out this movie is almost
kind of like a predecessor of that um i
haven't seen that one but i have seen
like a lot of reviewers that have
compared it to that and saying this was
almost kind of like
you know like i said if that was kind of
like a precursor to promising young
woman if jennifer's body came out
nowadays i think it would be a lot
better received i just kind of feel like
in 2009 the marketing was shitty
people didn't really get it you know and
it was kind of a shame but
i'm happy to see that it only took a
[ __ ] decade for people to like start
reassessing the movie and you know
appreciating it for what it was and for
what was intended because this is
actually i'm not gonna say it's like a
brilliant
movie or anything like that but this is
actually like a really fun entertaining
uh and actually pretty thought-provoking
movie
and i know that you know a lot of people
like to [ __ ] on uh megan fox because
they they thought she was just like hot
pretty dumb girl or whatever but she's
actually really great in this and the
fact that she
is perceived or and particularly in 2009
was perceived as hot pretty dumb girl um
they do actually play on that really
well in this movie so i really can't
imagine like anybody else in that role
uh but yeah she's actually great in it
and uh amanda seyfried is in it as well
kind of uh playing her best friend and
their interaction is just uh really
fantastic but like i said it's just a
really fun
horror comedy and it's just nice to see
it getting its due after all this time
because it was just so
controversial back in 2009 it really
didn't need to be it just seemed like
kind of a
con you know just kind of this
conflation all these stupid things like
kind of crashing all in together and
there's actually a pretty good i watch
like uh parts of it but there's actually
like um et live a couple years back they
did a kind of a little round table like
an interview with diablo cody and megan
fox and they were talking about this
movie and they were talking about like
all the dumb [ __ ] they got from
marketing and
and uh some
horrible [ __ ] that they you know that
they had to put up with like in light of
it so that's actually really interesting
to watch if you want to see that as well
so what we have in jennifer's body
is you have there's actually like a
prologue
where amanda seyfried's character whose
name is anita lesnicki even though she's
called needy uh which you know for a
nickname and
that is interesting that that's her
nickname because
it you know it kind of describes her
character but it's also kind of ironic
in a way too which uh maybe i'll get
into in a bit
so at the very beginning uh you're she's
basically narrating and she is in uh
sort of a mental hospital or prison or
something like that and she uh is coming
across as very violent like uh super
strong she's you know kicking this the
nutritionist lady across the room and
all this other kind of [ __ ] and then
she's uh so there's that and then she
kind of goes back
and tells us uh what happened like to
lead to her being in this situation
so the whole story takes place in this
kind of small backward town in minnesota
called devil's kettle this is not a real
town but the devil's kettle waterfall
that's kind of a plot point in this is
actually real actually they say in the
movie because the movie came out in 2009
there's actually this weird like
whirlpool and they said well you know
the scientists have been like throwing
stuff down in there but they can't ever
figure out like where the [ __ ] comes out
so they don't know like where
like this water goes down this hole they
can't figure out where it's coming out
uh i think i'm not entirely sure but i
saw like a couple other reviews of this
and they mentioned
that the devil's kettle mystery like
where the water comes out had been
solved in 2016 but i'm not entirely sure
if that's true so that was like several
years after this movie came out but uh
yeah so the devil's kettle waterfall is
real but there's not actually a town
named after it so they did name the town
after it in this movie
so you have uh needy
and her best friend is jennifer check
who's played by megan fox now megan fox
is again one of those real alpha female
like hot [ __ ] chicks
but her and needy have been friends
since they were little girls and there
does seem to be some genuine
love between them uh as far as you know
jennifer being
uh you know there for navy and stuff
like that but
uh in the sense you know in in the same
way as like a lot of uh
female friendships are during teenage
years
uh it's kind of like a toxic
relationship as well because
jennifer is
a way higher like social status um than
needy is you know she's way hotter you
know she's kind of like queen of the
school type thing it's weird because a
lot of the reviews say that she's a
cheerleader i'm pretty sure that's color
guard i don't think she's a cheerleader
because she's got like a flag and stuff
um it's weird because the poster like
has her in a cheerleader outfit i'm like
i'm pretty sure she's not a cheerleader
i think it's color guard but whatever
close enough now needy is kind of more i
mean obviously amanda seyfried is a
beautiful woman as well but they kind of
like nerded her up for this one you know
with her hair pulled back she kind of
has like dorky clothes and like kind of
big glasses and she's kind of nerdy but
i like that they didn't do this i mean
this movie like subverts so many kind of
like tropes in that way they make needy
like less you know socially adept you
know obviously
she's friends with this hot girl they've
been friends for a long time and she
looks up to her
but needy's got her own [ __ ] going on
she has a boyfriend who's actually quite
named chip and he's actually quite a
nice dude um and he seems to really love
her and seems to really care about her
they actually do have a sexual
relationship which is not judged in any
way which is nice to see they don't make
her like this virginal i mean she's kind
of shy and bookish and stuff like that
but they don't make it like she's this
you know complete loser type thing like
they normally would do in a movie like
this she's just like a normal girl
that's a that's not as glamorous maybe
so uh so again they have this very toxic
friendship where
needy seems to look up to jennifer and
also um and i don't even want to say
this is implied because it's pretty it's
pretty outright
that they have
like sexual or romantic feelings toward
one another too and there was kind of
like this was another mistake of the
marketing i think because they were
trying to appeal to teenage boys back in
2009
they really played up not only megan
fox's hotness but they also played up
the kind of infamous scene where uh
jennifer and needy like make out
now
uh you know diablo cody has said you
know i kind of knew that they were gonna
do more with that you know and they were
gonna make it like this big titillating
kind of thing
but honestly if you see it in the film
and you see it in context
it's not really it's almost kind of like
she you know she has even said and this
is the way i took it as well
that i was trying to show that female
relationships of this type uh you know
in your teenage years
go way beyond friendship like so she's
like i was trying to get across this
intensity
and also um you know just these kind of
like unexplored feelings that the two
young women had towards each other so
when you see it in the movie it's kind
of like i'm not saying it's not hot
because it is but it's kind of the way
that
it's almost kind of like a lot of things
going on at once it's like confusion and
you know i you know do you want this i
kind of want this and it's like you know
what i mean so it's just like a lot more
complicated than
i guess some people perceived it as uh
so yeah so but there is some kind of
like sexual tension between them and
it's interesting too because as the
movie goes on even though jennifer is
ostensibly you know the hotter one the
more confident one you know the the one
that all the boys are after
um she kind of needs to have needy
around as well
and i think you know in her own way
she's jealous of needy because needy has
as i said a really nice boyfriend that
loves her she seems to have her [ __ ]
together she's very smart and so i think
in a lot of ways it's and again it's
kind of like this [ __ ] up like toxic
relationship which does happen a lot
with girls this age i experienced it i
know many people uh that experienced it
as well
and
so she loves her she's jealous of her
but she also likes having her around
because
needy makes her look hotter by
comparison and it's almost kind of like
she needs her around to sort of like put
her down and you know push her down to
make herself feel better because at
bottom jennifer is also
very very insecure
and she's very very aware that the only
p reason that people like her is because
she's beautiful
and that is kind of like [ __ ] her up
so
it's kind of like a really complex and
it's a really good um exploration of
sort of teenage girl friendships of this
type where one is
well as i said hotter or more popular
than the other and it's almost kind of
like the hotter popular one
you know is jealous of the less hot
popular one but also
likes having them around because they
look better and they like having a
little bit of a whipping boy like to
sort of build themselves up there's
actually like one scene in there where
you know they're going out to see a band
and jennifer says to needy wear
something cute and needy says in the you
know in the narration that you know that
means a very specific thing she's like
you know wear something that won't make
me embarrassed to be seen with you but
also wear something that doesn't out
shine me you know what i mean so it's
like you still have to be second tier
but
i can't be embarrassed to be seen with
you so it's like this really complicated
really [ __ ] up like codependent uh
kind of relationship
so near the beginning of the film uh
jennifer and needy
go to this kind of honky tonk uh groddy
ass bar called melody lane where this
indie band is playing and she says
they're from the city i don't know what
city that is
they're called low shoulder
and she's really into them and she sort
of like has designs on the lead singer
whose name is nikolai and she's like
yeah we're gonna go to this bar even
though we're underage and we're gonna
you know get in good with the band
so they go there and it seems like
nikolai is interested but he's kind of
like trying to figure out if she's a
virgin or not and he's convinced that
she's a virgin because like oh i've see
i grew up in a small town like this
there's these kind of girls and all they
do is like flaunt their titties and
their sexuality around but they never
give it up now you find out that
actually this is not the case uh
actually
jennifer has been uh sexually active
since she was in junior high school uh
so she's not anything like he's
picturing her as and another thing
that's sort of ironic about this too is
that i kind of feel like in a lot of
horror movies you know sexual
promiscuity is equals death uh
particularly a lot of slashers this
again kind of subverts that trope
because needy is sexually active with
her boyfriend and also uh jennifer has
been sexually active and that's kind of
the only thing that keeps her from dying
because as it turns out the bar during
the show catches fire and a lot of
people are trapped in there a lot of
people get killed and needy and jennifer
get out and interestingly they're kind
of and jennifer is actually in shock and
she's also kind of had too much drink
and i kind of think the implication
although i don't know if this is uh if
this was really explicitly
uh said or not but i kind of feel like
maybe the band members drugged her a
little bit because she's acting a little
bit out of it but like i said it could
be shock too from seeing this tragedy
and seeing everybody burning to death
and everything so they get out the band
gets out and seem like super unconcerned
uh they're just kind of like oh there
you guys are we wondered where you were
we hoped you got out okay uh let's go
somewhere safer like my van you know
what i mean and uh so uh needy is like
absolutely not uh as you would but
jennifer is kind of like [ __ ] up she
you know as i said she came here to see
these guys because she thinks the lead
singer's hot so she's kind of dazed and
again maybe drugged i'm not entirely
sure
so she goes with them and
needy can't really stop it now for a
long time you don't actually figure out
what happened you're assuming that you
know these these four indie dudes and
this is a very like emo like a lot of
the soundtrack is like super emo and
[ __ ] like that so if that's gonna bother
you then probably this is like this
movie is like so 2009 it [ __ ] hurts
you know what i'm saying it's like 2009
hot topic like the music and stuff but
that it didn't bother me i mean it was
kind of like i thought it was funny
because i was like oh yeah i remember
this era but um and it's really over the
top of it but it didn't bother me all
that much
but yeah so you're kind of led to
believe that you know probably what
happened is she goes off in this van and
they like gang raped her because that
looks like that's what's gonna happen
but that's uh actually not what happens
you actually don't find out until later
uh you know something happened but
you're not sure what
so later on that night uh needy has to
go home by herself and she's home and uh
she's calling her boyfriend being like
man i don't know what the [ __ ] it's like
you know [ __ ] jennifer took off in a
van with these four guys and i'm pretty
sure uh something bad happened and then
jennifer turns up in her house looking
all kind of bloody and [ __ ] up and
then she starts doing weird [ __ ] like
she pulls like a whole like rotisserie
chicken out of the fridge and starts
eating it and then she pukes this black
[ __ ] all over everything and um
so you know needy's a little but what
the [ __ ] happened you know what i mean
and she won't really tell her but then
the next day at school jennifer shows
back up at school and she looks totally
fine
totally fine uh and she's just kind of
like but she's a little bit different
though because
um obviously the fire that happened the
night before uh killed a bunch of people
including i think they say like a
teacher or two and like eight students
and they're dead so there's kind of like
this big like tragedy type thing
and everybody's really bummed out about
it but jennifer seems real callous and
like she doesn't really give a [ __ ] he's
like oh god here we go blah blah we're
getting a tragedy boner for that kind of
thing which this kind of part reminded
me of the whole part in heather's about
big fun you know what i mean like
teenage suicide don't do it it's like
it's that kind of vibe because what ends
up happening is this band low shoulder
they come out
and they you know kind of give a story
to the media that they helped all these
people out of the fire even they
absolutely did not
so
they get famous off the back of this
tragedy of this place burning down and
all these people dying
so what you find out later on
it goes on where jennifer is essentially
starts luring
boys at the high school
into her clutches and of course they all
go with her because she's hot so the
second that she shows up and being like
hey come in the woods with me for a
second or hey why don't you come to this
abandoned house and they're just like
okay you know what i mean so they just
like follow along and uh she ends up
eating them
uh what what transpired uh that night of
the fire
was the band took her away they took her
to devil's kettle
and they told her that they were
essentially going to sacrifice her to
satan so that their stupid indie band
could get famous
and
this scene it's funny because this movie
is actually like funny it's a horror
comedy
but the scene near the end of the movie
or i guess like toward the end of like
the second act where you know jennifer
actually tells needy what happened and
about the sacrifice
um is actually pretty [ __ ]
chilling
because
they take her to devil's kettle they tie
her up and basically tell her yeah you
know do you know how hard it is being an
indie band these days we figured like
sacrificing a virgin to satan was the
only way that we were gonna get famous
and so
you know here we are and this we're
gonna do and basically she's freaking
the [ __ ] out obviously because she's
tied up and she's gonna get [ __ ]
butchered
and they are
so callous and they're just like
laughing at her and like singing that
8675309 song and like all this others
and it's horrifying and she's just like
laying there screaming like like begging
like for them to not do it like i'll do
anything you want i'll do this and it's
just really it's really really
horrifying so it's like it's i want to
say it's like a tonal shift it is but
it works though i mean i kind of think
even though the rest of the movie is
like kind of funny i think the horror of
that scene is really good like in
juxtaposition but yeah it's really
horrifying especially it's just they're
just like laughing at her like they
don't even give a [ __ ] and that's like
really scary so it turns out that what
happened
was that they
you know in their wisdom like thought
she was they had her number and that
thought she was a virgin and obviously
she wasn't
so what ended up happening was that they
sacrificed her and she did die
and the demon came and they got what
they wanted like they got famous as i
said off the back of the fire
but it also the demon got inside
jennifer and essentially brought her
back to life so now she is um you know a
demon in jennifer's body and she has to
eat people
uh specifically boys although she does
say later on that she goes both ways so
she could eat a girl as well i guess but
she's basically just eating boys as an
almost kind of like and i don't know
this is just kind of how i read it but
because she doesn't necessarily go after
the actual dudes that did it to her um
who have moved on
um she actually just goes after other
dudes some of whom are innocent so
she's you understand like why you know
and you kind of feel like oh it's like a
revenge movie
but the fact that she goes after
innocent people including needy's
boyfriend chip which is [ __ ] up um
just because she's jealous because you
know needy likes him better than her or
whatever that's how she perceives it um
so that makes her not as likeable either
even though she's still sympathetic so i
like as i said that her character is
very complex she's kind of an [ __ ] to
be honest even from the beginning before
she gets demonically possessed um you
know she's a kind of a dick to needy she
does seem to love her but she's always
kind of like doing little passive
aggressive like digs at her and [ __ ]
like that like to sort of you know
winnow down her self-esteem like to make
herself look better
you understand why she does it because
she's
again very very insecure
but it doesn't make it okay but the fact
that needy
loves her friends so much that she's
willing to
you know essentially she really needs to
fix this problem and she's kind of but
for a while she sort of like defends it
but she after she finds out what happens
um she kind of says i'm the one that
needs to destroy her
because i'm her best friend and that's
just how it's gonna go so that's
basically how it goes on um and she
actually does end up destroying her in
the end
but because obviously no one really
believed that she was possessed by a
demon she uh needy ends up getting uh in
trouble essentially for murder
so uh so again it's really kind of like
i i really actually had a good time with
this movie and i feel kind of bad that i
didn't watch it
prior to this because i feel like it's
always kind of been on the outside it's
like oh yeah i really need to see that
because i um and i thought about it
again when i watched um the 2015 movie
the invitation which was directed by the
same director as this uh karen kassama
and even though this movie is wildly
different from that
karen kasama does like she does all kind
of different movies but um and i loved
the invitation so much that i was like
oh yeah she did do jennifer's body back
in 2009 i should probably get around to
that and then i just never did uh so now
i feel kind of bummed out that i didn't
really get around to it because this is
actually like a really decent
horror comedy and it really has kind of
like a lot to say again about these kind
of like toxic female friendships you
know the way these you know certain
types of dudes like victimize women for
their own uh you know advancement and
it's all this kind of stuff so i do kind
of feel like if this had come out more
recently
i think it would have done a lot better
because people would have got it um you
know what i mean i feel like in 2009 i
don't really know like people weren't
really ready for it or like i said i
think a lot of people were disappointed
because the marketing
wasn't
um was really stupid like the way they
marketed they just took the complete
wrong demographic and because there was
such a backlash against megan fox
because of the [ __ ] she said about
michael bay and you know against diablo
cody because they people thought she got
too successful or they didn't like juno
or what the [ __ ] ever and so it was just
kind of like this whole
you know
perfect storm of [ __ ] that sort of
conspired to
make everybody really [ __ ] hate this
movie even though this is a perfectly
fun you know it's fun it's gory it's
funny you know it's got some sexy [ __ ]
in there too but it's not really
you know and like i said it has like a
lot of really interesting things to say
um and it's kind of a shame that it took
this long for people to maybe appreciate
it so as i said if you kind of like dark
comedies like heather's this definitely
has a heather's vibe to it um definitely
has a ginger snaps kind of vibe to it as
well there are a lot of thematic
elements that are similar so if you like
that kind of thing like i said mean
girls promising young women that kind of
which was more recent that kind of stuff
if you like those and you haven't seen
this
then i would totally recommend it it's
kind of a shame what happened to it but
it does seem to
be to seem to have gotten a critical
reassessment i found like a whole bunch
of articles in [ __ ] new york times
and vox and all these av club and all
these other kind of things saying you
know talking about the the reassessment
that it's gotten and being like yeah it
sucks what happened to it back at the
time that's what happens sometimes and
it sucks but there's not a lot you can
do about it but uh yeah so jennifer's
body is on
amazon prime i think if you have amazon
prime you can watch it for free and i'm
pretty sure it's also on 2b for free at
least as of this recording um so if you
haven't seen it or you didn't see it for
back then because it got terrible
reviews um you know give it a shot uh if
you
if it anything i said about it like
sounds like it would be interesting to
you um i really really liked it a lot
it's like i said it's not
the most brilliant film ever but it's a
perfectly fun
kind of uh you know kind of more
substantive horror comedy that's kind of
more
you know
sort of centered more around you know
female characters teenage girl culture
and uh you know which you don't really
see a lot and it does kind of like turn
some tropes like upside down which i
kind of really liked so uh yeah so check
it out and if you've seen it uh let me
know did you love it did you hate it uh
did you know about the backlash uh you
know that happened back in 2009 did you
know about the critical reassessment i
didn't really uh but i'm interested to
know what everybody thought about it in
the comments so let me know and that
will do it for this flickers of fear i
will see you guys on the next one bye